the fact is that i'm agreeing with you
that there has been a demonization that
we need to get our hands
around in the way in which people are
doing this understanding okay so you
agree that we're demonizing kids
we're demonizing um kid
we're demonizing white people for being
born
and are some of our students white
people
what are some of our students white
people yes
okay so we're demonizing white we're
demonizing white kids why don't you just
say it
right we are using language that makes
them feel
less than um for nothing that they are
personally responsible for
for my my main audience that maybe
hasn't heard about this yet everything
you're saying is probably not that
shocking to them because i think
so many people have now seen this sort
of woke thing
infect so many schools and you know high
schools and colleges and now
virtually every institution and
everything else so all this is happening
and was there a moment where you like
what was it in you that was like i have
to say something now because i think a
lot of people the question of the day is
sort of
what what makes people stand up because
i think we're watching a lot of people
fold
and i'm glad to see that not only did
you write the piece and and got in touch
with barry and i'm curious how that
happened as well
um but then are willing to do press
after and really keep
you know walking through the fire on
this thing
well once it's you know once it started
to cascade i began to feel
a real sense of exhilaration and duty
that i was doing the right thing
so that carried me through up into the
present day
um i wasn't sure when i started to ask
what a white feeling was or ask these
things in the chat
um you know how it would play out i
hadn't planned it
it started something my impulse to do
those things initially was simply to
to provide a you know those questions
were genuine but i
asked them because i felt that students
needed to see a teacher
an authority figure model for them how
free discourse is conducted and i hadn't
seen anyone do that
before and i felt that this was
something that i could do
and as it started to cause all of this
chaos around me i realized
well this is actually pretty important
and the more chaos was going on the more
i actually
felt that it was important to pursue it
yeah i mean it's so extraordinary
because obviously you know the story of
brett weinstein at evergreen and
so much of my audience knows that story
of course and
we've heard so many versions of this so
then what how did you get in touch with
barry and how did this whole
article get written and and the whole
piece there
the public part of this you know not
just fighting back right yeah
right well um my contract
uh they offer a contract year to year
and so
in my contract my current contract
expires the end of august so i had to
sign the contract for the next year
by april 15th and part of the
contingencies of that contract were
that i attended restorative practices
designed by the office of community
engagement
to address the harm that i'd caused
students of color and
other students in the school but they
would not specify what those practices
would be until after i signed
so i was in a bind there so i found
incredible you know some legal
representation through fair the
foundation against intolerance and
racism
i spoke with barry who's in a on the
board of advisors
and you know she suggested that i write
a piece about my experiences and i wrote
um
i wrote 5 000 words at first i had a lot
to say
and then we edited it down to something
that was more digestible
um and then i did another draft and then
she had some tweaks and then i you know
so
so um the editing was very helpful
but those were all my words and i'm
really you know i'm really
pleased with the effect it's had right
so okay so you put the piece out and
then
you know then then the hate starts
coming you know you get you get support
from
some quarters of course uh but then the
hate starts rolling in
and then what's the next thing that the
school did because this is where it
really starts
kind of going off the rails well it is
interesting i mean i got
overwhelming support through predictably
through
through you know barry's subscribers and
you know
through an email that i that i had
placed there but
i was curious how the school was
reacting my contract you know this the
article came out in the 13th
my contract i had to sign by the 15th i
hadn't gotten back to them yet
and then on the 14th i believe i
received a threat from someone within
the school community
it was not a physical threat but it was
a threat to my livelihood my well-being
and it was basically everything but
so you know i reported the threat to the
administration
i reported it to the head of school and
then
they tried to use that as a pretext to
keep me out of the school
to keep me from teaching in the school
saying that you know well you maybe you
feel unsafe
because of this and i said no actually i
don't feel unsafe i'm merely bringing
this to your attention to something on
your radar you should take care of
and then they said they tried to reframe
this threat as an opinion
and they said they would pull the
opinions of the other students and
faculty to see if they felt safe with me
in the building
and so when they came back to me and
said no actually your your students
don't want to be in your classes so we
need to keep you
home and in fact we're going to take
away all your classes
unbelievable okay so you know they were
indifferent to my claim that actually if
someone makes a threat aren't they the
ones that should be staying home
right and why why is the teacher
punished for what
you know another person did yeah
unfortunately my lack of shock is just
well not only because i know i know your
story but i mean i just
we know this story over and over again
sort of false allegations
then gaslighting and reversing
accusations and and all of these things
okay so we're going to play this audio
clip now can you can you just set up
what happened between you and the head
of the school
to give a little context and then we'll
play it and then come back
sure so the head of school george
davidson sent a letter to the
whole community saying that i had you
know in my article
i had misrepresented um you know the
conditions at the school that i had
substantial omissions
in there and they reiterated their
commitment to anti-racism
and and they you know they offered me
they
they relayed to the school that they had
offered me this chance to
participate in a in a in a sub-committee
of a committee
um that would be heavily supervised so
you know as to sort of try to co-opt
whatever what i was saying
um however their claim that i had you
know
misrepresented things or left omissions
i responded to that with my own letter
you know saying that um
you know i i actually had in
conversations with george
you know he had clearly acknowledged to
me that he had grave doubts about
the school's own policy and that he
specifically had said
that there was a problem with demonizing
whites
at the school so i released that letter
publicly
um in response to his letter and then he
released a letter back
saying that this was in his words you
know i misquoted him
i attributed to him things he had never
said nor would ever say in the press
my actions were unprofessional so he was
impugning my character and
and my veracity so at that point i felt
i had no choice
but to release you know clips of the
conversation which i had recorded
because i was worried that it might come
up in an
employment dispute right i mean it's
it's actually quite incredible because
you did this like an absolute pro
in terms of the emails back and forth
and then doing this recording and
well let's let's let the recording stand
on its own so let's throw to that
let me ask you something george because
i think those are i think there's
something very different
about having a single experience where
you
make sense of it right and having a
teacher an authority figure
talk to you endlessly every year telling
you
that because you have whiteness you are
associated with
evils all these different evils these
are moral evils it's not the same as
taking like
a physical thing because it doesn't
affect your your
your moral value that's the problem
the the the the fact is
that i'm agreeing with you that there
has been a demonization
that we need to get our hands around
in the way in which people are doing
this understanding okay so you agree
that we're demonizing kids
we're demonizing um kid
we're demonizing white people for being
born
and are some of our students white
people
what are some of our students white
people yes
okay so we're demonizing white we're
demonizing white kids why don't you just
say it
right we are using language that makes
them feel
less than um for nothing that they are
personally responsible for okay so that
clip is quite extraordinary because
in essence he's basically saying yes
you're telling the truth yes
so you felt kind of good i guess at that
point
that that that you released it yeah i
mean i
if if you back me up against the wall
and you call me a liar
well he left me no choice uh i have a
reputation that i have to protect
especially since i'll probably be
looking for another job soon
um additionally i want to make clear
that the word
demonization was his word i never
suggested it to him
that is you know that's why i i was
actually quite shocked
that he felt that way and i was also
shocked
that he hadn't taken any action on it
because what does it mean if the head of
school
knows that students are being demonized
for their race
and does nothing except share it
privately with
and saying publicly something completely
different so this was
just you know it was gratifying in a way
which is why i kind of said thank you
thank you but it was also really
disturbing
because nothing had been done or seemed
would be
planned to be done he did make some
mention about
you know they were going to have a
meeting at the end of the year or
something about it
but that seemed totally inappropriate
to the to how serious the problem was
right so so to to bring this all to now
actually so there was a little confusion
i think at first
whether you had been let go or exactly
what had happened
so you are still employed by the school
but they're just not letting you teach
is that is that correct that's right
that's right um
as of now i still have email access um
i don't receive all of the
communications i'm not on all the
distribution lists
as it turns out but at this point i
still am
i still am connected to the school in
that way
i have been asked to be on this task
force um but i think i've said all i
really need to say for them to
to work out it out themselves uh frankly
i don't think there's
much i need to add to that if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about
academia instead of non-stop yelling
check out our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell